JAY SMITH: Go deep.
ED HOFFMAN: I got it, I got it.
JAY SMITH: All right.
That was a good
catch right there.
ED HOFFMAN: Well, I mean, you
popped that one up real easy
for me.
JAY SMITH: All right.
Well, enough about baseball.
What do you have
for us today, Ed?
ED HOFFMAN: So today, we're
going to talk about Istio.
JAY SMITH: Istio?
What's that?
ED HOFFMAN: So Istio
provides an abstractive view
over your service mesh.
JAY SMITH: Whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't know what
a service mesh is.
Can you explain it to me?
ED HOFFMAN: Yeah.
A service mesh describes
your microservices
and the applications
and their interactions.
Istio helps you with the traffic
management, observability,
and security.
Istio helps in decoupling your
application code from the PAP
form in policy controls.
If you're the GM, and
Kubernetes is manager,
Istio is your hitting,
pitching, and bench coaches.
JAY SMITH: Great.
So, how do I set it up?
ED HOFFMAN: Let's jump right in.
JAY SMITH: Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ED HOFFMAN: So the first thing
that we're going to do here
is we're going to just check to
make sure that our cluster is
up and running.
And now, we are going to
create the cluster adminroles,
so that we can create
RBAC rules for Istio.
Now we're going to download
the latest release of Istio,
and it'll take a
little bit of time
for us to get here
and go download it.
Now that it's downloaded,
we're going to uncompress it,
and we're going to
enter the folder.
So now that we've
entered the folder,
we're going to set
our path so that we
can run the Istio control.
And now, we're going to deploy
Istio core components using
the pre-created YAML files.
So this is running through.
So this YAML file creates
the Istio system namespace,
the RBAC permissions,
and installs
all the components for us.
So now, once we have
that set up and running,
we're going to
configure and set up
the system for automatic
sidecar injection.
We'll set up the config
mapping, and then
create a cert keypair
for the webhooks.
Once this is done, we will set
the CA bundle in the webhook
install YAML file, and we will
install the injector webhook.
So this will give us the
ability here, whenever
we deploy an application
with a labeled namespace,
we can actually have the Istio
sidecar automatically injected.
Just take a little bit more here
to install the last little bit.
So now we're going
to just go real quick
and just apply this
file that we've
been updating to push it all and
to have this running perfectly.
So now that that's all good,
what we're going to do here
is we're going to label
our default namespace
so that any application that we
deploy in our default namespace
will get an Istio
sidecar injected.
So now, we're just going
to check to make sure
that that label's
been added, and now we
can see here our label's
been added to the system.
And now here, let's just go
through and let's check out
a sample application,
a simple hello world
application, that responds back
with what version it's running.
So let's go here and let's just
very simply apply and deploy
this application to verify
that the injection is working.
So now, what we'll
do is here, we're
going to run the kubectl get
pods and just check the status
to make sure that the
pods are up and running,
and they are up and running.
JAY SMITH: Wow.
That was really easy.
You must have hit that
one out of the park.
ED HOFFMAN: Yeah.
Setting up Istio on GKE is
easier than stealing a base.
JAY SMITH: I don't
know baseball.
But please make
certain like, share,
and subscribe to this video.
ED HOFFMAN: And if you're
working on something cool
and want to reach out to us,
click on the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]